so i'm going to enable opening requests
and go blind
i'm prepared oh dear
bong cloud again redeemed from reformed
cats
okay opening requests
bond cloud
okay so i'm still going for this like
tumbleweed
uh can you play the one cloud against
the sicilian
i don't know i thought bon cloud is more
i guess oh my king
okay all right so i'm this is my final
bon cloud game d5 is a good move
let's try and trade queens trading
queens would be really nice
i'll play f3
i don't mind this some nice kind of
pleasing symmetry
c4 is probably a good move
you can play the bong cloud against
anything that's the beauty of it
oh i didn't know there is so much
potential for beauty
bishop
i feel like this is going to go terribly
wrong
also my opponent i feel like is a strong
player c4 was a very good move
okay let's let's try and trade queens
of course black doesn't want to maybe
queen c2
i wanted to run my king here maybe i
have bishop e3
and bishop c5 could be coming
all right how bad is this bishop here
so this square is very very weak and we
might see some infiltration
i just want to trade
let's start by taking
leave this move your rook d3 is probably
coming
look at this move yeah hitting the pawn
i do want to like try and just trade
everything on the d
file if i get the chance
move
maybe now bishop e3
so if that goes for this and i have the
idea
actually maybe i could take i also have
the idea of knight h3 to f2
i'm realizing i can play rook d1 and if
queen takes a2 i move back and trap the
queen
could be nice whoa what is this move
i guess that's a move if i do this
so c3 is coming this is a whole point
black's winning back a piece black's
also considering this move
which is terrifying
so if i do this takes takes
takes takes that's okay for me
oh it's not okay for me
if i take there's bishop c5 and my
king's overworked
ah there goes another position
let's try this i'm going to lose a piece
but i do have some pawns and some hope
bishop f2 good move
about my time very little time
here rook c2 so the idea is to double up
and
just create some tension or create some
tactics yeah so now i'm threatening the
knight takes b6
let's pawn storm make the pawns
the shape of a bathtub
maybe the smooth threading the fork
gonna probably trade a pair of rooks
still threatening the fork
if this oh that move
i don't know what to do b3
ideal knight c4 yeah knight c4
threatening this
okay here maybe i can take
this is an okay trade
interesting let's attack the rook
idea this and this
the ftxi fork
tricky i don't want to play this move
it doesn't really do much though
okay now i'm winning a pawn
losing this pawn but maybe winning this
pawn
run away duh
good move got my time
let's trade rooks please
g4 coming oh it's crazy
we're both queening wow what is this
let's just be safe
yes yes i had to time it
i had to do a slight triangulation wow
wow what a game what a game
oh the game man yeah black's king and
bishop were set up perfectly for the
pawn promoting
that was so nice that was so bad though
that
i i didn't take the oh the queen was
defended
okay so yeah maybe this is the best
course of action
it's so easy for black to fall into this
akini it's a very key move too if i play
this first then
black will queen with check and not
steal me
whoa it's gm rains but actual gm
whoa it's admiral burner okay the things
thanks so much gm rains and admiral
burner
um maybe that was youtube worthy that
was like another weird stalemate trap
combined with the bomb cloud okay so i
got all the bomb cloud out of my system
which i'm happy about whoa admiral
berner
with 5000 bits thanks admiral berner
i appreciate that um let me read off the
sub names
or maybe should i say bye to the youtube
people if you're watching on youtube in
the future
say hi to the twitch chat and i'll see
you
even further in the future